My granddaughter has issues with her gut.
Is this a type of patient that you take?
Yes, it is.
So we can still help a person like this.
I mean, it would be like anybody else.
Go on our website.
Now you can just click over begin here
and you'll see schedule down
and this is what all of you can do.
The schedule down page will have the option
to schedule an initial consultation
or we call a case review.
You fill out the intake form and you schedule self-schedule.
Otherwise, you can call the clinic
and talk to us during the week.
And this on the schedule down page on our website,
I didn't make a screenshot of it
but below here on the page is where you would schedule
for a follow up visit.
And that's where again, you could choose to do a Zoom.
Follow up visit as well.
But yeah, no matter what health condition
the person has will still do an initial consultation.
I may recommend different labs.
I may recommend getting a course.
If the person's having gut issues,
maybe the detox course,
maybe more likely the autoimmune course
that's more comprehensive.
So yeah, we still help people
with all sorts of different conditions,
even though we don't attract a lot of people
with different conditions because our website
is all about cancer.
But certainly we have a lot of relatives and patients
as patients slash members.
So yep, we're gonna try to help as many people as we can.